[Music]
of course i'm always patient i've never
had a year where i haven't grown
why because the [ __ ] well is proper
this portion is like with me so i think
this is when you need to get selfish
like you need to ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast
that's how you get [ __ ] done that's how
you figure stuff out this
is the television and the television
is the radio the 40s [ __ ]
we're all present and accounted for
thanks for showing up gary we appreciate
it um
i'll kind of like we do normally i'll
just kind of walk you around the room
we'll do a quick little 30-second intro
on each of the folks
on the zoom here and then we'll do our
second round with the deeper
conversations
um and like i typically like to work
with you
a little farther away from you we're
going to start in california we don't
have a ton of international folks here
we'll start in california
and derrick did arrive he just got up
from a seat
um derek's here all right we're going to
start with derek and surish
uh derek go ahead and say hi to garyvee
all right um hey gary nice to meet you
i'm uh
derek moore santa barbara california i'm
kind of a split personality i am a
orthopedic spine surgeon but in my
training i started a startup company
that i've been growing for the last 10
years and
um you know that's who i am and my
mission in life is making sure that
company becomes financially successful
meets all the goals
and i'm kind of at that point where i've
been doing both the company
and my practice and it's game day if i
keep doing it the way i'm doing it
company is going to fail so i got a lot
on the line and what's and what's the
company do derek
we are an ed tech company think of it as
a hybrid between linkedin
and a kaplan we have a half a million
physicians 112 million page views per
year
it's a giant in orthopedic education
and understood and what's the name of
that
the name if you google search any
fracture
ortho bullets comes up on google so the
name of the company that's recognized is
orthoable it's our flagship
we have another brand called med bullets
which is for medical students
uh and then the kind of parent company
is this bullet health that
is an unrecognized brand but if you look
up ortho bullets you know
we've been around for a long time we
pretty much rate number one for many
fractures on google
and uh yeah and then that was supposed
to be the five second one
no we've also got saresh who works with
derek and he's also
he's kind of like the right hand he does
a lot of the marketing and he's a v
friend holder so cerise say hi what's up
gary
and the and the knicks basketball and
crush it and jab jab jab right hook i'm
in moods here
yeah yeah hell yeah now i'm i'm a huge
fan i've been you know following you for
almost
a decade now i briefly met you at your
first k-switch drop
in 2017 and then at vaynermedia's voice
con in 2018
you know i know people tell you all the
time how you change their life for the
better but
you know i can't imagine that gets sold
so firstly i just wanted to say thank
you
for that um you know i'm an orthopedic
surgeon by training but
i went into medicine for all the wrong
reasons you know we're at the 4ds
but in my house growing up with indian
immigrant parents you were going to be
one of the 3ds you were going to be
a doctor a dentist or a disappointment
you know for me
you know medicine was less of a calling
and you know more of a telling you know
my parents told me to do it
so i was you know as you can imagine
pretty unhappy throughout my
journey of becoming a doctor and then i
found your content and you know learned
a ton about self-awareness um you know i
was hoping to get self-aware hair but
you know wound up with a rare
resourceful robin but
anyway um you know you really allowed me
to become that self-wear hair and
ultimately led me down a path to
kind of pivot out of clinical medicine i
still you know practice
you know um in a few days a month just
to kind of stay in the game but i
now working with derek and really you
know
finding something i'm way more
passionate about and you know at
bullet health and you know really um
being able to align with um
his vision and kind of help you know
kind of people like me not make the
you know same mistakes so um yeah
thank you so much you got it yeah and
scooting up to santa cruz we've got
jeremy kirby who is the founder and ceo
of dugout creative
uh who's got a lot of overlaps with what
you're passionate about gary so jeremy
go ahead and say hi
yeah hi gary thank you thanks for
everything you do um
again like like joe said jeremy kirby
dug out creative um
10 years ago started out as baseball
camps
everything we do is basically around the
baseball industry and
started out teaching youth in santa cruz
county with camps
eventually moved on to academies travel
ball teams
uh facilities running travel tournaments
basically everything that
that was youth baseball uh covet hit
shut everything down
no youth sports anywhere so it sort of
forced us to pivot
and we we had been doing uniforms and
fan gear and stuff for
for local teams and uh teams across the
country for that matter
and uh ended up sort of pivoting and
um took advantage of a couple of viral
moments i don't want to say which ones
they were but
if you see the pouty face on a t-shirt
from a
from an la dodger player you know who it
is
moment kind of took off thought we were
going to sell 50 shirts
thousands of shirts later we're sitting
back going i guess we became a merch
company overnight
continue to put out designs sort of
iterated on
the city collection stuff that we had
launched where we wanted to be the first
one to do
a baseball jersey that was city inspired
because we knew it was coming
um after the nba did it we knew that it
was eventually going to break off into
into major league baseball and
uh we did that that sort of helped put
us on
now looking at things we we wanted to be
able to look
at different things and not just be
known as a merch company we wanted to
experiment everything else
uh so we jumped into the gaming industry
ran a couple
uh ran a couple mlb the show tournaments
last year as kind of some testers under
a different alias
and then just hired uh four or five
gamers
uh in the mlb the show space uh
streamers on twitch brought them on
board
and uh are now creating merch and sort
of trying to build a community around
everything baseball and like i said
earlier if it's if it's
cool and it's baseball we sort of want
to experiment and kind of be curious
about it and build a community around it
and monetize through merch uh through
merch through tournament fees through
advertising through sponsors for events
a little bit everything you got it cool
let's work our way into kansas city
uh dr malachi say hi to garyvee gary
glad to be on finally be connecting in
this way
um it's been a phenomenal session so far
so your team from joe
to james to claude they've crushed it
just fyi
and by the way i've got um your first
book just pointed it
there you go so i own all the books i'm
looking forward to a new one
um so i'm an accidental entrepreneur um
i'm a
moonlight as a pastor at night but
really running a couple businesses is my
full-time occupation now
i started a digital digital agency after
i finished my
my doctorate degree in digital marketing
and it's done
well and it's more solo solopreneur
few contractors but in helping people
with their marketing i've discovered
there's more holistic business problems
so i've pivoted
to do business coaching um kind of
operating off some stuff that
um donald miller does with business made
simple university
i have a passion to see other people
succeed now maybe more than just help
them do well in marketing i want them to
succeed at large and many different
things
sidebar note i'm an ultra marathon
runner um
run lots of miles every week but just
grateful for you grateful for your team
excited for this session seriously fired
up for it
i'm excited too brother we've you know
we've interact you've been so active
with my content through the years i'm
very grateful for that and i'm happy to
see you
he also bought a hangout hawk so thank
you
i'll be seeing him much more often yes
and uh now we're gonna swing over to
atlanta we've got nicholas strand you've
actually got one of his shirts gary i
sent you one
uh but nick from choose your attitude
say hi to gary hey gary nice to meet you
thank you um
yeah i um i started to choose your
attitude
um i am actually naturally a roadie
traveling roadie um i'm a video engineer
putting all the led screens together
that you see at major
concerts um walked right out of college
right into
my passion um lifelong passion but
as you know everybody has a journey
everybody you know goes through life
and um 2012 i lost my mom to cancer
2017. i lost my wife of 10 years the
cystic fibrosis
as you can imagine life was tough but
she had an amazing story
she inspired me a lot but those three
years were tough
until 2019 i woke up and the left side
of my face was paralyzed
um i thought it was a stroke um but it
was bill palsy which
has come back luckily but if losing my
mom or brianna wasn't enough um it was
my wake-up call that i needed to write
the book about brianna
um and in my uber focus
uh craziness when i focus on something i
go
all out so in five weeks sun up sundown
i wrote the book loving someone is dying
um
right there um and then writing that
um brianna was very intelligent in uh
you know
knowing kind of the afterlife you know
she knew that she was inspiring but she
wanted
to leave something that would that would
you know be bigger
and as i was writing it i didn't even
realize that the quote she had created
choose your attitude create your life
and i actually have a tattoo on my arm
right here of her handwriting and so as
i was writing the book
this brand it then i i realized the
power behind the quote
um and so knowing that you know in those
in all that death and all that heaviness
and all that trauma
um the norms that people go through in
life
they they struggle at society suppresses
it right
um and so my goal as i wrote this was
trying to help people
um got it you know do that and so that's
where the brand came from is that kind
of funnel effect
um you know your welcome mat is the is
the brand and then
you know the create your life is is you
know
the deeper stuff so it's pretty cool
yeah um
that's where we're at and then just as a
kind of a struggle just to kind of show
um april 7th is when we tried to launch
and then
march 10th i lost my career um since the
music industry went from 100 to zero
and so investing everything into this
i've basically managed to
limp through without any income or
anything so
that's the other part of the sub and
down to jersey
the dirty jurors gary your homeland uh
we've got
podmax josh eric go ahead and say hi to
gary
what's going on brother thank you joe
hey gary really cool to be experiencing
this very now moment
um josh carey eric cabral were the
founders of podmax
um at its core podmax is a training and
event company for entrepreneurs and
thought leaders
where we um we give them the chance to
identify
practice and fine-tune their meaningful
message
and then we help them get out that
message predominantly right now through
the podcast medium
we do this through a few verticals our
main top of the funnel
uh vertical is our now
virtual event pod max on the calendar
every six weeks
and that's basically an all-day virtual
event where we bring podcast hosts
we match them with the client
guests of ours that we've been working
with and think of it like matchmaking
for the podcast industry
they record on multiple shows relevant
to their industry
all in the course of that one day in
between the recordings we have a variety
of keynotes
plenty of networking built in and
um and and just a a great vibe of
personal growth and
development uh we each came from this
because
we each found the podcast space to be
you know
life-saving really wow yeah
yeah brother uh you know like you man
born raised and and die hard nick fan
unfortunately
um we'll get our parade someday brother
uh but yeah i mean
i was in corporate america for over 20
years and uh you know
built up some muscle and some some some
superpowers while there
and then realized you know you know i've
been building and creating wealth for
for people who don't necessarily know my
name and then when i got to the level of
uh you know
seeing the numbers and like wow i made
millions for these
uh these huge fortune 100s you know
maybe i could try to do this for myself
uh so i jumped in you were a huge
inspiration to that um and jumping in
headfirst
and then developed my own personal brand
through that process and journey met
this fine gentleman
and we just started building stuff
together and figuring how can we create
and and best serve uh our audience and
and our tribe i love it where are you
guys based in jers
we're in trenton right now i love our
studio in trenton yeah and where do you
guys live
i live in manalapan yeah i'm in
robbinsville so all central jersey
yep yeah that's pretty cool all right
great joe let's do it
awesome got the context let's swing back
over to derek and suresh
uh let's talk ortho bullets and med
bullets uh you guys got about
we're gonna do about 10 minutes per with
gary and
and derek and sri and the rest of
everybody else
this is where you go very narrow like as
if nobody else is here
um we've found that luckily a lot of
themes hit others but that's what we
want to do in this session so
let's go wherever you want to go
derek you got to take yourself off
i told srisha i was going to let him ask
a tactical
question but i think i'm going to i
think i'm going to fire away on this so
so we we have a very strong identity yet
we have an identity problem the reason
is this company
is a manifestation of me when i went
through training
there were just things that were wrong
and i basically said
i'm never gonna let these things happen
to other people
it's a very political world you wouldn't
think it but medicine is very political
so i spent the last 10 years
i very don't think so i spent the last
10 years building the credibility the
impact i mean
our testimonials on our website are if
there is a nobel prize for medical
education
you would deserve it but now we're at
that point 120
112 million paid views but 1.7 million
revenue i gotta turn this into a
business i've
never wanted to charge doctors one more
time what is the url because i wasn't
able to find it
orthobullets.com ortho o-r-t-h-o
bullets like bang bang yep so
so i've never wanted to charge doctors
educational costs our life
is tough enough we shouldn't have to pay
for this stuff we're already in debt
i've always wanted to build a community
a social network
and we've done it we have half a million
surgeons around the world
but now it's okay how do we monetize
our page use we can how are you
monetizing now literally ad
sense like like lowest so right now
our revenue is subscription 50 coming
from b
to c the doctor's paying for educational
content
50 from a sas business model b to b we
sell to
training hospitals 90 market share of
all academic
so so you are
are doing you know 850
000 in revenue charging doctors even
though you haven't wanted to
exactly yeah it's a i'm i'm zeroing in
on a very interesting point
i don't know if this is a medical term
but it's definitely a jersey term
have you ever heard of the medical term
half pregnant
nope let me let me tell you what it is
you have incredibly good intent
you've built something meaningful
because it comes from good intent and
you built it out and
you know obviously probably did
extremely well in the sem
ecosystem i get it you
have this emotion and and proper one i
get it even the way you said it
it's kind of like why i do well i'm one
of everybody in this room
like even the way you said we're in debt
enough we're like
uh you know you're one of them which is
why your product's good it's why my
product's good
i'm truly pretty much everyone in this
room um
the problem is you've already
established the crossover moment
if you didn't have a monetization
against them at all
this would be a complicated brand
strategy
the fact that you've already done it
you're not winning any points from
anybody
by doing it small you're not getting any
gravy points they don't know that you're
not making that much money
they just know there's something they
can pay 9.99 for whatever it is
you're half pregnant because you don't
really want to charge them
and so like one of the places i would
immediately look if i bought this
business like
talk about a business that i would love
to buy
if you were like hey gary i'm actually a
huge fan
i want i'm done i'm like going fishing
i'm just done i'm good
and but i want to see this explode i
want you to have this business
you know that much traffic that seems
meaningful because you're winning sem so
it's intent based right
um it's you've got a
uh you've got a product service strategy
conversation to be had so
what are you selling
so the the reason we
we've created this product that's
incredibly valuable it's like
it's like a drug that cures cancer but
we don't want to charge the patient
so what we do is we convert that for
page views so we got
all these page views okay so now we just
have to convert that page view
to the business we believe in i got it
how much
which is i got it how much are the
physicians
uh actually paying the ones that do pay
they pay about 120 bucks per doctor per
year
right so you're saying it's all b2b
there is no doctors that pay
120 bucks themselves no half
are beaten so it's funny notice if you i
wish you could watch this recording
the same thing i started with is right
where i'm back at
for a second because you have so much
conviction in this i had to reaffirm
that just now because your mindset
is that you're like and i get it by the
way and it's a good idea by the way
was i'm never going to charge a [ __ ]
doctor i'm going to charge
it's going to be a b2bc it's a b to b to
c model it's not super complicated
however i'm trying to remind you that 50
of your revenue is b2c
with the amount of traffic that you have
and the cycles
that it requires to do b to b to c
i have a funny feeling your essence
is spending 90 of your energy to make it
a b to b business
and 10 on a b2c and yet it's 50 50 in
revenue
right pretty much
that's the most interesting part of this
diagnosis
that even though every part of you
wishes no doctor was paying
and that you probably opened up that
later along the way because you wanted
originally for it only to be to be
b2c it's still 50 of the revenue because
it is high value for what you're
charging at 9.99 a month
but remember of our half a million users
only three percent pay
i know but that's because you don't want
their money
right it's bingo bingo bingo bingo
so the question is and i'm saying if i
could get literally
what i'm doing right now just to give
you the diagnosis is doing this
you're sitting here and i'm just by
talking to you gonna
try to make you do this because i
believe that if i'm able to get you to
say
my friend i know we don't want to charge
doctors but they spend more than 120
a year on [ __ ] starbucks
and the second i get you there and i get
it because it's not i don't think it's
an easy hill because i feel like you're
locked in which is a me i actually
admire it and love it
i'm just trying to get you to not
demonize the 120
because the second you don't you change
the whole product and the whole thing
will tip
all right let me throw one thing at you
because we're running out of time
getting doctors to pay that money it's
hard work getting the
institution to pay that money is hard
look at your teacher's parking lot
there's no money in education
i got it i am very confident i can get
one dollar per page view by connecting
the right patient
to the right doctor you google search
femoral neck fracture
as a patient in the er you land on ortho
bullets i have all the information on
all the doctors so you wanna
you wanna you wanna build.com
um so what you need to do
is probably what to re match.com had 350
of the top engineers in silicon valley
you know it's important to say that
because people say things like this
without knowing those kind of details
batch.com raised hundreds of millions of
dollars to build an affiliate
transactional two-way marketplace
uber ebay home advise
like the businesses are very obvious but
if you're gonna go down that route
you need to start thinking about
fundraising
not about what your business strategy is
going to be
yeah you're right i mean you what we're
saying is if we want that market
opportunity you have to go into hyper
growth mode you got to raise real
venture you got to play in the majors
and get out of the miners
and what i feel is um
that if the intent was to get a 120
dollars from everybody every doctor
that the business would explode
that's my hot take on i've seen this
pattern a lot
i think you're sitting on a lot of good
gold
and i think you have to make one of two
decisions
yes we're gonna go raise capital hire a
true cto
infrastructure to become a great
affiliate
based business two we're gonna heed
gary's call
and actually be okay and believe it is
not hard to get 120
because of how much karma points we're
putting on the board of this remarkable
product
and then make it front then make that
the front-facing
aspect of our business which will then
help us start converting
9.3 percent instead of three percent of
our traffic
because it was built to capture it right
now it's not built to capture that
so you think with a 120 112 million page
views
still be a content subscription business
don't try to be a pageview business
a page view well you don't want to be a
pageview business because a pageview
business
is advertising dollars you want to be an
affiliate business is how i heard it
right
i i think the real interesting thing is
the lead generation the match.com
connecting the page that's affiliate
yeah you want to be an affiliate
business
to be an affiliate business you're
running on incredible math
you know how like people think they go
on google and webmd and think they're a
doctor and you guys laugh at them
that's how i feel right now about a web
business
for you to be an affiliate business
you're going to need
a tremendous cto and real capital
because you've got to make all the math
work
whereas what i think you've done is
built incredible guilt
and equity in the ecosystem and with a
front-facing facade switch
be able to get a lot more 120s 10 a
month
only 9.99 a month and then use that
capital to actually
put you in a year in a place to go
higher and become
i think you have to become a 10 120
doctor business for 18 months so that
you're in a power position to become the
affiliate business
and get to what in revenue that just
becomes your expenses right like revenue
is always predicated on the ambition and
reality of cost of running
right it's it's not a textbook ideology
it's what are you about james knows that
he hasn't met too many operators that
care less about bottom line
profit than he met with me it was always
top-line growth because i was building
growth scale why i was building for
myself there's a
so to answer that question i need to
know what the heck you really you know
to your point i heard you
enough revenue to make sure you don't
have to shut it down because you're
bleeding money
let's start with that
cheers let's move on see what else we
can get to all right jeremy
you're up all right thanks so
we um we're sort of in uh um
we're in a crisis i guess of trying to
figure out what it is that we are
so i i can tell you right now
i mean that's a media company
that is contemporary and culturally
relevant to
a niche that has incredible economics
and passion around it
and then what you have to do on the back
end is spend
all your time and energy figuring out
what you get the most enjoyment out of
what you're the most capable of and what
has the most margin
in selling got it okay so that that's
perfect that's exactly what i was going
to sort of segue into is
we've been confused as to what to post
what to
what to or how to build the brand
because we were never really sure what
our brand was
and i guess you you either have somebody
around you that went to
a good college or buddies that work in
marketing
because what you just said means nothing
it is the number one reason vayner is
disrupting the industry
that br brand is what a human being
feels about you
you're first of all in the business of
leveraging other brands
to build yours let's start there i love
for sure right i love the mix you're
gonna make a joke about
rj barrett that's cool to me i want that
like you're
you're you're fanatics you're not
you know right so i think that you know
when i hear you say that question i
immediately go to like
what is he reading who's in his ear
what's he thinking about
because i believe in bran the most by
the way the most
um but i don't think i think you
actually know what you're doing
volume social media creative well
inevitably
your brand what's snl's brand snl's
brand is the output of the feelings we
all have
based on all the skits the skits weren't
cohesive
the cultural relevance was cohesive yeah
but the way that everybody wants to
build brand is make every snl skit the
same
okay got it yeah and i guess
it sort of scared us for a little while
there because we were so
bottom of funnel with facebook ads for
for quite some time
um because we put out all this merch we
put it for sale we ran tons of facebook
ads spent thousands of dollars
straight bottom of funnel didn't try to
build a brand because we were we were so
new we were just trying to keep the
lights on
sure after kovic shut things down and so
then
you know one of the things that really
really triggered things for us
was when facebook had that glitch i want
to say it was about maybe six months ago
when
all the ad accounts got shut down our
sales went to zero
overnight because we weren't running any
ads and you know after watching you for
a while i i
i agree with you 100 as far as brand
means everything and we failed to build
a brand
because we were constantly pivoting at
whatever was new can i give you a good
piece of advice
sure build your brand organically on
tick tock like your life depends on it
okay four tick tocks a day okay
all brand no sales
okay so in that in in a way
building can i can i give you yeah can i
give you a couple other things
sure please for everybody facebook
groups
are a secret weapon okay
for all of you whether it's jermaine
who's going to start a
small business tech of new york society
whether it's you with baseball whatever
or you want to make 50 of them baseball
in ohio
like facebook groups for you building
brand tick tock
go ham and then finally
every day for the rest of your life 85
cents
can go for sales to keep the lights on
but until you die
you always spend at least 15 cents on
[ __ ] that feels like brand
whether that's sponsoring every little
league team in the world
because you thought that was right or
whether it's running ads on tick tock
after you get organic things you're like
wait a minute now i know why gary sent
me here
it's the new facebook you got it yeah it
definitely nailed it as far as uh
we're depending on other creators to
help
build our brand uh because we're we're
bringing on
we're not connected can i give you can i
give you a good one please
um you know how
champion and polo and louis vuitton have
like
signature clothes that are just massive
logos
yes you should create one for yourself
you should create a mascot
like the [ __ ] chicken that the padres
used to use or to philly fanatic
you should create your ronald mcdonald
and you should
give away those [ __ ] t-shirts okay
in that 15 cents it's brand it's a lost
leader
yes if you make something an epic
character
and it's a free [ __ ] t-shirt inside
of every box and it cost you four
dollars and nine cents
that's a that's one of the ways you
spend 15 percent
got it got it yeah we had we had sort of
experimented with that too when we were
going live a few different times on
twitch we created a character called uh
we called them squatch where it was like
a major league minor leagueish
uh uh squatch character and we made him
fat just to kind of
play you know kind of poke fun at it to
kind of be different
i would i would refurbish that and get a
real animation
real 3d like really go there okay be
friends
okay that was the other i i guess to
jump into the next question i had too is
um should i be i mean i should always be
cautious i guess but
is there one of the things that we've
been thinking about is sort of
doing a lot of research and jumping into
the nft space
um we plan on running uh a creator
league
within uh the gaming space in baseball
we plan on running uh tournaments for
for the audiences of a lot of a lot of
our creators
we started thinking about you know all
these guys have their own merch line
which we're creating and fulfilling
and and uh delivering for them we sort
of thought about creating some type of
package deal that we could sort of
put out as an nft but the thing that's
sort of
uh i'm a little hesitant on that is that
if we're selling these nfts behind a
personality
that is sort of uh i want to call them
an independent contractor but they're
basically an independent contractor of
ours
is there anything that we should be
super cautious about where if we're
selling
a package deal with a guy that might not
you know he might decide next year that
you know what i'm out i don't want to
stream anymore
i'm going to go get a full-time job you
need to be careful
by over communicating to the audience
that that might happen
okay got it you know look at me
yelling about nfts and then saying 99 of
them are going to be bad investments
yeah okay
yep got it all right jk thank you
nice i'm going to go over to atlanta
nicholas strand from choose your
attitude nick
let's go all right uh thanks gary um
so i uh as you can imagine uh
with with all the journey going on um
this was actually all kind of a
a train that i kind of got thrown on if
you will
and when i say thrown on i don't mean um
you know
obviously i'm thankful for my life and
everything
so i started writing the book all of a
sudden you know
the shirts become this brand you know
visionary i see all this
being in the production industry nothing
is impossible
i mean i'm literally paid to you know
ask to make
the most difficult things happen and so
knowing that this is all possible put it
all together boom
covet hits i lose everything um sorry
not
everything i got it you know so moving
forward has been kind of a struggle
um here i am i've got i've got the
vision i know how far i can go
um but at the same time i feel like
every single step forward
of success uh kind of you know is is a
hundred
steps back because you know um not
getting no
not getting past um you know the gr not
getting to a growth point
right um because everything costs money
i've got the podcast i've got the book
the book hasn't really gotten its light
yet
because i've been focused on the brand
why the brand because it's not as niche
as the book
um and that's also why i created the
brand
um so what did nick what nick what do
you want to happen
so i think your scenario is interesting
to me because
you know could i argue that you know you
you see things like life is good and see
that as a
very big business and you're like oh
that like is that what we're talking
about here a little bit
so yes all of that and so just like just
like brianna's quote
um it's so choose your attitude as the
brand that's the welcome format to start
the conversation
i got it create your life is the other
part where it's actually
you know the the how would you like
let me ask you a question if i said i'm
actually a genie from the future
yep and i can do anything right this
second
yep and i said and the only but the only
thing i can do is
actually just dictate to how you not how
much
yeah but in which places you would make
your money
in which places you would make your
money how would you like
to make your money if i said you're
gonna make two million dollars next year
how would you break that down if if you
had it completely your way
i would say the money would come from
the brand
but the effort would be in the mission
and be able to share
that i understand that i understand yep
we're gonna have to separate
the altruism from the business because
i'm on board
but you didn't start a non-profit and
moved to a farm
and eat off the land so you're in the
business lane
yep so in that business lane
how would you like to make your money
not the i know the bus of course the
business has to make the money that's
what business does
how right like
how would you like to make your money so
are you asking like the brand or are you
asking like
so you have a brand right yeah exactly
the brand the brand is is only speaking
and books like it doesn't make money
just for existing
yep right yep uh
how would you like to make your money
my brain goes to the brand but i i i
think you're going that's what that yeah
that's why i think you're vulnerable
yeah because i think you're not making
the most like i felt it from the setup
and i definitely felt in the first few
minutes which is why i'm pressing here
because i want you to win and i'm
excited
there is no such thing i'll give you an
example
hey johnny up phil knight
hi phil knight how would you like to
make your money
the brand i understand it's a swoosh i
get that
how oh i'm gonna sell running sneakers
to wholesalers they're going to sell it
i'm going to make a margin i'm making a
sneaker the wholesaler's going to buy it
years later if what i decided to do it
on a golf ball because we signed the
best golfer in the world like
you know we sell stuff right
you know amazon jeff bezos wanted to
sell books today
his company bought mgm and they're gonna
make money by owning james bond's ip
because they're gonna because you're
gonna sign up for prime
got right so how do you want to make
money
so i think you're going deeper into like
the doing speaking gigs the podcast
to um the social ad channels and those
type of things
i would assume yeah i think the thing
that stands out for me brother
is have you thought about possibly
bringing in a business partner who can
be the business person
so yeah so that's kind of yes i've
brought
i have that kind of actually in the
works of a marketing
uh team owner and then also so i
actually
uh traveled with dave matthews band and
so i'm working with dave matthews bands
um trying to kind of team up with his
apparel guy to kind of get that and then
i would focus
i think i think it's a little bit
different is would that apparel guy be
doing this full time
so like let me let me tell you what i
what i noticed
i think you're the creative director of
this company
for sure you're the assets correct you
are a hundred percent not the person
that's going to build the business
i i that is my that would be a weakness
yes
well saying a weakness is building a
business in the context of building a
business
is like saying i can't swim but i want
to swim
well so here's the deal so well not
here's the deal but
my life has always been selling myself
right as a roadie
and such i understand getting hired for
pride that i understand
yeah and by the way that whole world's
coming back and we'll be back and so
we got to keep that in mind to me what i
see is
a very interesting scenario where i'm
trying to figure out what happens over
the next 18 months so that you win
my intuition is the roadie thing's going
to come back and you're going to make a
decision on
you know how much of that do i want to
do two
and this is your life mission at this
point this is
[ __ ] your tattoo yeah your wife
passed away i mean this is
huge so i want this to succeed
on the flip side to make a brand
pop is hard yeah and you have to be an
operator and be
good at it on multiple levels i think
you're the inspiration
and the essence but if you're going to
make choose your attitude of business
i think you need to hi i think you need
to partner with somebody that owns a
piece of it as well
who's actually an operator because i
don't think that's your calling from
you you can't be at this place answering
my questions this way
and gonna end up being the guy who's
actually gonna build the brand and build
the business it's not gonna happen
right in fact and that's okay by the way
that's amazing
well and that's that's been my biggest
struggle throughout the year is
like as as a production person i'm the
first guy to know like okay i can't do
this so i need to build a team correct
so to me to me though at the ambition
level that you have
and the importance that this is that
should be the only thing on your mind
who who am i good that's it nothing else
oh so
it's it's good to hear you say that
because a lot of the business people in
my life have told me you have to keep
working
until you're dead and then you can start
getting people and in my head it's been
no i need to build a team
it's all about because what you need to
do is find
someone that looks like me that's in
between like like if i was in between
let's say
a month ago like let's make pretend i
was the dream candidate
a month ago i freak out and say you know
what
as much as i love business i'm now ready
to go into a
different version of that that is far
more non-profit i'm gonna build
something with a mission
and then we stumbled on each other
somebody introduced us i would have been
perfect because i could make choose your
attitude
enormous i would have taken 49 of the
business
you would have had all control because i
would have been empathetic and said hey
this is your [ __ ] you know
i want to own 49 so you always have
control i want some protection in case
you get mad at me
and then i would go build the [ __ ]
business
while gleaming inspiration from you
yep putting you out in front telling the
story
that's where you are at nothing else
will work
thank you i've been feeling that way for
a
while
it's imperative that you hit joe q
before you decide to
do a deal with carol yes because i want
us to double check if we feel good about
who you're picking
because the you in this situation yeah
often picks
not good people fact no i appreciate
that
for sure i do have to ask one more
question um and i know you have
a good rolodex um because my podcast is
of choose your attitude and it basically
hits a lot of people
of uh heavy heavy struggle and stuff um
i was going to see if you might have a
couple guests that you might be able to
throw my way that
yeah i can joe and i will stories yep
joe package it for me so it's
packageable
yep all right thank you appreciate all
right we're going to backtrack a little
bit because i skipped over the middle of
the country which is unintentional
dr malachi say hi to gary let's go with
you i thought it was intentional
yeah i've been homeless too i've cried
somewhere else right no worries
um gary i've got three questions joe's
kind of guided me on this so i'll give
you the overview and then unless you
think i should go in a different
order i'll let you answer them i think
they're probably going to be meta but
maybe one you'll just grab onto so
you got it first one's probably gonna be
about a podcast related question
the second one's gonna be about uh
digital agency in small town america how
to kind of stand out and the third one
is more because i've pivoted to more of
a business coaching
um business and and questions related
around that based on the fact i actually
heard that in a
marketing for the now or something that
you had a business coach so
if that order sounds good to you i can
just go through them and see what you
grab ahold of
yeah the third one we we hired a
business coaching organization for the
organization
i i didn't per se i mean i had three or
four sessions it was lovely it was
awesome like
i enjoyed it but i um i
i think many i think you have to know
how you learn
the reason i've never really had a
business coach is the same reason i was
a terrible student
i don't learn from a dictation
opinion point of view i learned through
osmosis
of the living it so but if you learn
and by the way even just watching how
you follow me
you may do great with a business coach
what you want to make sure
that you do with a business coach is
make sure that she or he is not preying
on your insecurities
well what i mean by this i actually
became a business coach
because i've been helping people i
remember marketing and i just was
curious because
i also know your opinion on a lot of
people charge for things that really is
free out there
um and people i think i look it's the
way i think about even 40
you have to be able to put your head on
the pillow and feel great
if you feel like you're spending
meaningful time and you're and you
really feel like you really
see for example i really really
really really feel this is underpriced
like
i know what i told derek is right not
even like [ __ ] a debate
it's very easy for me to audit i've had
too much pattern recognition
i have too much like it i'm just in the
prime of my career
and he's at a very clear
and present scenario of one of those two
options he's gonna now
think about that it i know for a fact
what i told nick is a hundred percent
right for him right if you
get if you truly believe in your sense
that that's what you can do
it feels amazing not shitty the reason i
hate it is people just
take courses to sell people courses
and just want to make money like they
don't give a [ __ ]
i'm i hate 4ds can i tell you why
one person that doesn't think it's good
is a vulnerability to me
i just enjoy the [ __ ] it's why i don't
be friends like
i'm finding it like these guys don't
realize how vulnerable 4ds is
like i'm getting more busy like well
with me they'll be great they're amazing
but like with me
i do this because i like it so much and
i learn i like listening
it's like a win-win-win-win situation so
i think for you you just have to make
sure you're pumped and you believe in
your [ __ ] and if not
get your get your knife sharper totally
totally
well let me just ask you that let me ask
you the podcast session go up the list
and tell joe's do it
so all right so i actually get ready to
launch podcast i know you've been
preaching that for years
i'm not ready to do it but i'm the
paralysis of analysis
um i'm obsessed with seeing how the
people succeed literally
for me i want to interview a wide
variety of people but i've been caught
like because business coaching stuff
ultra marathon running stuff do it all
you're such a fan of my stuff
my stuff's all over the [ __ ] place so
do you brand it
personally yes
because then you're then you're the
catch-all okay
all right well that's literally call it
the dmo show
perfect perfect well that answers that
question i'm gonna move up to the next
one
let's do it all right second one was you
know why it's important by the way i
want everybody to hear this
the more broadly you brand it the more
flexible you are
i got [ __ ] on you know for making like
for not like calling myself like
everybody made fun of me on twitter i'll
never forget it a lot they're like
oh that was stupid you should have been
wine guy or wine dude
at wine dude or wine gary why didn't you
why'd you do that gary
and in my mind i'm like because you you
don't understand i'm 32 years old like
like i'm going to be a lot of things i'm
going to be gary vee i'm going to be
gary vee like you know and so
that's what you you're a young dude you
might
you might want to really talk about
chocolate making
in seven years and your podcast can do
that if it's the
you know dmo show very true
yeah no perfect that answered that
question exactly um
and one of these days we'll have your
team on as
they're awesome all right so i run a
small digital agency right now in kansas
city here's the exact question
some of these some of these businesses
don't even have a marketing budget
what are the ways a small digital agency
in 2021 can
stand out in the crowd of agencies and
deliver the most value to clients
if i were you every night for multiple
hours
i would search content in the greater
kansas city area
on instagram facebook and twitter
by businesses i would click the content
i would then audit all three four of
their social
platforms and i would send them an email
of a 20 10 12 minutes audio recording
of an audit of what you see they're
doing well or where they can improve
on their content and leave it at that
it would [ __ ] dominate you would do
unlimited business
because one out of every six people
would just give you the business after
the
how do you price point that because i
probably feel like and i know claude
jumped on this and intent wise i
probably undersell myself because i'm
afraid to ask the
larger retainer you know i also you know
don't let jim no
james knows this i don't love charging
either like believe it or not
i think the right answer is always a
little bit more than the last time
until you get 25 no's in a row and you
found your answer
perfect right so if you're charging
where are you right now 500 bucks a
month 500
months 500 a month per platform
[Music]
so literally literally i'm not kidding
you decide to follow my idea
sure enough the third one the six pizza
locations
guy gal writes you back you get into a
convo
literally literally you tell them 550 a
platform
and the next one's six and the next
one's seven
perfect perfect and i'm also creating
all right by the way
talk about that's advice that's how i
built vaynermedia i had no [ __ ] clue
you know it would be like three thousand
dollars a month they're like okay good
i'm like [ __ ] okay
next one's like five dollars you know
[ __ ]
like you just tried you know eight
thousand
who was your first client in vaynermedia
our first clients were five thousand
dollars a month
there's this enormous debate on the
history of vayner media
actually the first client flat out is
absolutely gillette
we had a we were outsourced vendor
by somebody else for gillette to do this
event
in vegas social media content we got
paid 80 000
for something i thought was worth nine
dollars and
literally if i didn't need that money so
bad just to pay the first three people i
probably would have
talked it down but you know you know
beggars can't be choosers sometimes
um and i remember thinking [ __ ] man
people paid this much in these big
like it was but then i didn't want to
build that kind of business
that i wasn't proud of so we built this
five thousand dollar month thing and it
was a very quick
jets nets campbell's
uh nhl the nhl like we
pepsi the jets nets campbells
every one of those companies i just
mentioned my brother aj registered their
facebook and twitter account on his
computer
wow
wow last question and by the way i thank
all the ethereum that you probably own
now will help you buy the jets
fyi well
the tax head i have at a 4200 base when
it's at 2800 has me in the real pickle
so i'm not
i'm not as cool as i look on tv aren't
you glad you told him when you did
versus this week when the ethereum's
half the price
no because i didn't convert the ethereum
into cash yet and i have a tax
vulnerability so i'm in a little bit of
my own anxiety these days
um last question and it goes back to the
business coaching thing if business
coaching was your business
yeah it's what would seek what would
make it the most profitable is it
products
is it events uh what do you think you
would do if you were doing a business
coaching business
to try to make it you know he does do a
business coaching business
yeah mentors yeah it takes a piece of
the upside
um i i think i would have done it the
way i did it
which is i would try to make the money
in speaking
and instead of taking it from peop i'm a
very big disadvantage
excuse me advantage that i have to be
careful of i
am gonna end up being a really great
all-time businessman like not
just okay and so i have to be careful
because that actually is like talent
that's like lebron james saying to you
hey just practice shooting all day
that's cute lebron you're
a [ __ ] all-time athlete there was a
lot of things that
of course you put in the work but there
was a lot of things that came along
as i continue to go through my career
i'm like oh [ __ ] i really hit the
[ __ ]
dna lotto at this thing i need to be
careful
to not get of course oh of course i
didn't [ __ ] try to monetize anybody
i didn't need to i was capable of
building 100 million dollar businesses
on the side and giving everything away
for free
not everybody has that luxury but but
the
seed still sits there doc the more you
and this is why i love derek so much but
i'm trying to tweak him in a different
way
the more value you provide without
asking for something
the more leverage you have to monetize
um
but they're also much like this program
after years of never considering
something like this i'm like wait a
minute this is good
and this is my own ideology which is why
derek got such passion from him because
i was in the meta moment
i've never charged anybody for business
advice now this
exists so we're right here doing it and
i'm trying to get him to do
for his business what i kind of did
because
people are winning people are winning on
their investment with four d's
and and i think people would be winning
on the because the second derrick
and sorry decide we're gonna go ham on
ten bucks a month
that product's gonna get epic
because right now it's subconsciously
just like the secondary thing
until we can get to the [ __ ] thing
and then we'll [ __ ] not charge
anybody
i get it or or
you make it [ __ ] crazy good
perfect i'm the best salesman in the
world because i don't sell anything i
don't [ __ ] think is remarkable
whether that's a pinot grigio do you
know why i'm so pumped about v
friends because everyone's gonna [ __ ]
destroy it
me neither all right let's move on
thanks all right uh are we up
is that yeah are we up okay cool cool so
gary uh we have something well
two questions we're not gonna probably
get to plow through three of them
because the first question
is massive and we want to go deep um and
then the second one is actually a huge
ask but so the first one i just want to
set it up and then
and then and then i'll give you the
question but you know we're in the
podcasting industry
and you know we have a very unique event
you know that matt people like to call
us where the matchmaker is from yep i
heard it
podcast right and then and it's live
it's all in one day
we get masterful keynotes we've probably
had everyone in your c-suite
a keynote and then you know we do
training prior during and even post
uh to help them craft their messages we
have dynamic
mcs and when we're not there we even
have other people to take you know
our seat so you know from a scalability
and then duplicating ourselves
uh aspect but then we realized recently
it's a [ __ ] funnel like we created a
funnel that's not the business
we thought it was the business dude we
were selling tickets two three thousand
dollars because it was live it was
all live and then when it went virtual
we're like holy [ __ ]
people want more from us they want to
buy stuff from us and we have nothing so
then we created
several products we're like okay what do
we do let's build a thought leadership
platform a personal brand liftoff so we
call podmax
liftoff that's our rolls royce eight to
ten grand right
and then we got a month so then we got
um
our our podmax talent which is
podcast booking we can get you on shows
because we built a network of podcasters
over 50 strong right now we're building
and growing it
and then we have podcast production
because a lot of the people that come
through they don't have podcasts but
they got it we're inspired by what we're
doing so like i understand yes too
so so the biggest challenge josh and i
and our team are facing
is how the hell do we get more brand
awareness at speed
number one the last part of that
sentence destroyed you
yeah at speed yep it's been a couple
years though bro
okay how much more i mean like
we're we're super impatient i understand
yeah and pay in patience leads to bad
execution gotcha always
i would argue that probably one of the
primary reasons
that um that
it's been two years is you've been
impatient from day one
yeah i would say that's accurate right
so i think i think that
you really have to have that moment with
yourself and say okay cool we're
so young because you are yeah you know
like
yes i know there's 25 year olds i've got
some youngsters out here like i get it
but like you're [ __ ] young and so
like what if you actually didn't do it
impatiently for two years
like what would that look like you know
yeah like what like you know my question
now let's go a little deeper
what have you
so now you're saying okay gary we we've
realized the power of brand
because the way people feel about us
look at this now we want more of it
right but what have you been doing to
build brand or when you say it's been
two years
give me the arbitrary scoring mechanism
you've decided to create for yourselves
that have made you impatient when you
say it's been two years and we're only
here
well in context of the event
which we do um virtually now
um we we sell tickets to it of course
and we're it feels like a struggle to
get
10 or 15 tickets sold and
personally it feels like wait a minute
on paper
maybe this is just the patient's thing
i'm willing to accept that but it seems
like
on paper we should be selling out five
to ten times
more than that so you're selling 10 to
15 tickets yeah yeah
how much uh 700 average per ticket
to a virtual or to a real one to a
virtual that's expensive
yeah okay that's a good starting point
right like if you looked at your fellow
homies and here's body language
that's a lot have you
where'd you come up with that price so
so the podcast
uh booking industry charges anywhere
from three to five hundred dollars to
get you on one show
so we we get people on three shows in
one day plus there's keynotes and
there's there's training
okay hold on hold on hold on dude hold
on i understand now we're in a little
bit of a better place let's start
it's an eight-hour event the virtual one
is not just the content
we're putting you on show oh yeah you're
going to read it got it that changed it
a little bit for all of us right
now the question becomes and this is
very real
the quality of the podcasts
yeah i have a funny feeling if you said
hey everybody for 700 bucks
you know when you do our thing and every
one of you is gonna be a guest on the
askgaryvee show
on garyvee's podcast the audio
experience i have a funny feeling you
would sell [ __ ] 40
000 tickets so one of the things i
i've seen in businesses that have taken
this approach which i understand now
what you're doing
okay is they overestimate their
inventory
wow okay you you've decided ricky
thompson's podcast is
epic of the 50 the the market's telling
you it's not
there you go yeah okay so now let's play
it out and i think
i'm sure if i spent the day i'd be like
do you guys have [ __ ]
garbage 50 podcasts nobody [ __ ] gives
a [ __ ] because
you know i would i would love to be on
three podcasts for 700 bucks
right now to your point if you get me
rogan and
guy like and so my intuition is that
what you need to work on immediately is
the supply
wow okay got it so the market would be
treating you better for sure if when
they saw the list of the podcasts
they were things that people actually
wanted to go on wow
so the value because we have a tough
time
understanding or what the value is
because sure we're going to get you on
shows
but then what about the training we give
you to hone your message and craft it
and deliver it in a system
my intuition is you started
transactional from day one
in la in human form
[Music]
which immediately destroyed
the branding of your education
can you say that again what is that sure
yeah what does that mean it means that
the difference between me and internet
marketers that many people look at
is that when you're trying to monetize
from the second you met them
it's hard to have the relationship that
you're actually looking for
you're looking for brand which is called
marriage
your execution from day one with your
business was here's my room key
come and meet me in the room because you
were transactional from day one
okay this first time anybody ever saw
you it was
hey come to our conference and pay 700
bucks we're gonna put you on three
podcasts
okay you're also both very high when
you're high energy like us people think
it's good it's bad
i'm underrated because i come across as
maybe
full of [ __ ]
so you guys not only were transactional
but i'm [ __ ] loving your charisma
here
which immediately made 40 of the people
say these guys are [ __ ]
so you were left with 60 percent
got it that's so sick
do we have to do anything with that
piece of wonderful advice
i don't think i haven't toned it down
what you have to do is is
over deliver right i feel like i've
always had to i've always had to over
deliver
to compensate for being a bad like i
didn't have the things on paper or the
personality
that made the main world feel easy with
me i'm
uneasy they go to linkedin it says mount
ida college
they're like that's not good they click
a video i'm cursing they're like what
you know like it took me time
to show my merit
go read the early articles about
vaynermedia people made fun of us
in the ad world so our takeaways
are um patience which is your
your ethos your everything so patience
but then
but more importantly because patients
will come because i think
it's even more interesting than that
i'll call patients in this scenario my
sink we need to go to the well where the
water comes from
you will you too will be way more
patient if we fix the product
and you start seeing results you'll be
like this is fine
you guys will be super fine if the event
right if i know i already know you guys
without knowing you guys if event one
was 30 and the next one was 60
next one was 90 you'd be more than fine
yeah
you'd be patient as [ __ ] of course i'm
always patient i've never had a year
where i haven't grown
in my life super easy to be patient fine
why
because the [ __ ] well is proper
you can't in your business model you
might be overestimating the quality of
the supply
which then begs the question okay if
that's the case
gary we agree we're going to be
self-aware and naked now
right these are not the greatest maybe
it's not you know right
the next and maybe they are i'm just i'm
making some assumptions based on results
because you have too much energy and
pizzazz the only logical answer is the
podcasts aren't good
i'm completely commit by the way i'm
completely convinced that's actually
what's happening
right you know so what happens next
you go and look at the top 200 podcasts
in the categories you play and you
literally reach out to number 200 to 150
and try to cultivate value
[Music]
like you reach out to the carol thompson
show and say carol we want to be homies
we want you to be the keynote speaker to
our thing
we want to do we want to send you a beer
i don't [ __ ] know
but you need to get you need to fix your
supply
[Music]
wow we always quote you gary when
because this question comes up all the
time like every every other day you know
oh yeah we want to get into podcast
maybe you could create it for us or
we're going to come and get on shows
through your event
what's the roi on podcasts and was like
hey garyvee says what's the roi on your
mom
that's my that's my default answer by
the way there's a much better one
thank you over 100 million dollars for
joe rogan
and you're not joe rogan so it won't be
100 million but it might be a hundred
thousand
yeah ask iras
what the roi ask any single person that
said upon ask dak shepard ask anybody
who's done well it's led to books and
speaking all the things that our guy
nicholas the things that i want nicholas
to do once we find him a proper partner
let him just go and melt all of our
hearts
and not worry about running a business
it's a gold brother awesome yeah the roi
of a podcast is clear as day
yeah we always feel like we're too soon
you know especially
you're late just so you know you're late
podcasting has been a major player for a
while
but i mean in terms of events and like
pulsing an event that's strictly around
like
podcasting you're you're looking for an
excuse
you're not too late promise too early
excuse me
too early is ego talking
i'm just too early no you're not you
know what i mean people love that one
we're too early i'm like you're not too
early
too early is you're not getting results
so you're gonna blame the market not
yourself
gotcha joe i got i got one more one more
go ahead stick it in and i know this is
a huge ask
and if we won't take it personally if
you say no remember jeff remember jab
jab jab right hook
i saw you react to when the other
podcast guest thing was brought up the
list
yeah no no i'm not no i'm not going to
ask that i'm not going to ask that and
this you can say no to brother
and i know the jab judge but you know
i'll kick myself if i don't ask this
if you could say hey this is garyvee and
you're experiencing podmax
here's what i'll do for you yeah i need
here's why that's dangerous for me
your business model is a vulnerable one
for me
and malachi it's actually i'd actually
be okay to do it if it was
less it's so transactional
that i don't want to dilute my brand as
being that upfront voice
but if you separate them see one of the
reasons i always won was i always
separated my media for my business look
at my earliest stuff
i by the way this stunned me you'll
appreciate this because i got a lot more
of your jersey dna
right like i'm about it i was stunned i
actually you know what i'm gonna do
joe can you make a note to tell my team
to find this for me i have to look at
the first
seven four three episodes of wine
library tv
if we were best buds aaron josh from
jurors and you're like what are you
doing next week i'm like
i'm starting this wine show you're like
what is it i'm like
it's the qvc for wine on youtube that's
what i
would have said to you because before
that light went on on the camera that's
what i thought i was going to do
i don't know why [ __ ] this is
probably why i've become
obsessed with intuition and want to
become like the foremost expert on the
subject matter and learn more about it
i'm
passionate about this now more than ever
i think it's the most underrated thing
in our society
the light goes on i think i'm doing qvc
if you notice the first episode of wine
library tv is very expensive wine
very high end very premium and i think
i'm going to go sell this [ __ ] because i
first of all i back to what i said
earlier i believe in the wine and
by the way i ended up being right the
winery went on to become a major player
and those were 80 bucks at the time and
now they're 500 bucks a piece
it was all right but i thought i was
gonna say and something happened the
light
went on and i immediately
out of like some crazy subconscious
decided to become america's wine guy
not my dad's son who's trying to drive a
business for him
like and it manifested quickly somewhere
in the first five to seven episodes
i pan the living [ __ ] out of a wine that
we
desperately needed to sell and that's
what i'm
asking joe to because i want to go see
if i can see if my face does anything
because i probably was shocked my damn
self
that's and that's what i want you to do
that's when you will unlock
i love it thank you thank you you're
welcome appreciate you
all right well thank you gary for
joining thank you
as always um i'll take the last couple
of minutes to wrap up here we got you
gary good
court great to see you bye everyone bye
thank you scary youtube watcher what's
up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon